The Joe Rogan Experience did you see
what they did to the house of dragons oh
I found I bailed on that last week how's
the dragon put all new actors in that's
when I bailed exactly what yeah are you
doing and they were and the only
compelling actor on the show was the
daughter
what are you doing yeah what are you
doing so stupid you could have just made
her look older yep you [ __ ] idiot
shoot first of all she looked like a 25
year old actress playing a 15 year old
actress it would not have been a stretch
and she's supposed to look 35 right in
the next one it's like 10 years later or
whatever it is that's not hard to do no
you could do that yeah
why did you do that it's crazy and they
kept some actors
so they kept some and they look exactly
the same yeah
and then they just replaced people
and they said oh but we cast the first
people first and then they always knew
the SEC the other the people got
replaced always knew they were going to
be yeah that's still a terrible idea
yeah that idea sucks and it's not enough
Dragon I I want to see dragons I want to
see them fighting I want to see them
torching [ __ ] up they occasionally use
the dragons yeah very occasional if
threatened with the dragon a little bit
but nothing happens yeah but it's also
like this they had me until they changed
actors
and you know my wife was like [ __ ] this
like what the [ __ ] they just do to me
like what did they just do why did they
replace the the queen but they kept the
king they just made the king look older
but you got a whole new Queen it took me
like five minutes to realize that it
what was going on I was like who is she
oh she's her no what no no no no no no
no why yeah and the king I mean look who
am I to knock anybody's acting but like
I don't find the king to be very
uh
good yeah he's like I'm sure he's a good
actor but maybe he's not right for the
part but I'm no I'm not excited about
the king yeah
it's not compelling no but the changing
of the actors were giant cluster [ __ ] of
a mistake yeah like whoever greenlit
that like where was the adult in the
room
yeah is there another [ __ ] way here
you've got people committed to these
people for hours yeah and hours they're
committed these particular characters
now you're asking this like you have to
just accept that you have new actors
yeah so now I know it's all [ __ ] so
now I mean when they did it with the
crown at least they did it from season
to season and I think they I think there
was three different Queens I never
watched that it was good and I [ __ ]
hate the royal family I mean first of
all I can't believe
I just can't believe The Queen Is Dead I
feel like it was just yesterday that I
couldn't believe she was alive yesterday
all my Queens
um but I I'm not a fan of the royal
family but but that show is really
[ __ ] good Olivia Coleman is
unbelievable I haven't watched it but
you know if you're gonna do it every
season I guess as long as you I know
you're gonna do it every season okay
right okay suspension of disbelief but
not good season
episode five yeah what is it six
whatever it is yeah [ __ ] out of here
why'd you do that
like you could have made those people
look old it's not hard to do it's not
impossible you have people look like
[ __ ] dragons right you have uh White
Walkers you have all this makeup put
some old people making yeah on that
young girl change your voice a little
bit yeah [ __ ] are you doing and but the
the night is still the same you have the
same night he looks exactly the same age
like what are you doing and then they've
also got uh because of the time the men
are all dressed the same and they all
have black kind of wavy long hair yeah
and so you can't tell is that that guy
right or is that the other guy and now
all of a sudden you're replacing him so
now I got to make that adjustment right
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that
here's another Point there's another
real problem
this is a prequel to Game of Thrones
there's black people in the prequel
they're all gone later they're all gone
later yeah so what happened yeah there's
zero black people in Game of Thrones how
many black people are in Game of Thrones
I can't remember any
but there's quite a few in House of
dragon there's a lot so what's going on
yeah
you went through how many seasons with
no black people in Game of Thrones and
the prequel they're in every episode
yeah same island it's the same island
they go
and why do they all have white hair I
don't understand they're gonna address
this can we just have black people that
giving them white hair why did you do
that well there was some black people in
Game of Thrones weren't there
there were certainly the um those
eunuchs the slaves right there was those
those guys remember those guys that like
fought for her oh yeah but they were
eunuchs yeah and then there was
certainly places that people went that
had people of color
but they didn't have royal family like
in this movie it's royal family yeah
it's like the targaryens or the
Lannisters or whatever
what the [ __ ] man
crazy changing actors mid-show is so
Bonkers yeah it's just such a Bunker's
idea and they just said okay this is how
we're gonna handle it yeah
you just [ __ ] people's heads up yeah
you're trying it you're trying to hook
people into a show and just as you build
the character and get them excited about
them and she was good I like the Young
The Young uh Queen right it was great
and also like
her uncle the guy who molested her yeah
spoiler alert he's still around yeah
he's still around and he's the same
doesn't look any older
but she's like this totally different
lady now he's in the crowd he plays
Prince Philip in the crown